what is up reject nation greg here
john here we are gonna watch the trailer
for the green
night it's been a year since the teaser
trailer came out i barely remember it
but yeah either way i'm excited to see
the official trailer here
a lot of people were like you know a lot
of people were hitting both john and i
on social media we've had a busy morning
we did a
interview with heavy spoilers and then
uh did an interview with henry golding
for snake eyes
like immediately after and now we're
watching the trailer for the green night
keep a lookout for both of those
remember the heck they go up cancer in
the first minute of youtube because
they're weird like that let's watch
this trailer and see what comes to mind
you check out the teaser trailer
reaction from a year ago that i did with
john rocca but now i got the john
humphrey with me
which john is better vote below i
remember roca knowing a lot about this
lore
oh don't worry i read it once in high
school let's see how much
better you can be than roca that's what
this video is going to be about
[Music]
friends
ancient arthur yeah yeah
nah man
i'll go
[Applause]
oh
oh he's the bad guy for mission
impossible yeah i'm gonna learn that
actor's name now
cg fox
824 must have a contract with him
wow that's so gorgeous it's so gorgeous
wow oh
wow this is
stunning
all of this
that fox is my new favorite character
that is
hi i
i loved that so much
ah oh my god this just is are people
sharing this
no wonder people were hitting us thank
you a24
wow thanks for making this i remember
the first teaser trailer having this
honing in more on the ominous horror
tones and while that's like
very much prevalent here in the trailer
you at least get a little bit more of
that traditional fantasy adventure you
know what it feels it feels like if
denise vellante directed a king arthur
movie it's kind of
it's kind of i think just when you get
to like the yellow lighting i was like
[Music]
it just looks like a teddy bear the rest
of it not really i thought this was like
an
absolutely beautiful trailer the 824 has
thrown down so much i mean i know 824
has money but i didn't realize i had
this money or they just had like a great
creative team here
or just they know really well how to
partition
some of that money towards effects
because yeah like those giants and stuff
like that even the fox i mean i think i
feel like the fox is a fully cg
it'll be my favorite favorite character
for sure that fox man
oh dude i'm getting i'm already getting
little prince vibes over here
in terms of just the emotional
attachment i might have to that
there's like guiding spirit animal in a
way i love it i love it no this is like
super cool
and and obviously appropriately it does
feel like this sort of
classic fantastical epic myth of some
kind
and yeah to take this epic poem of sorts
and to bring it to life this way yeah it
is kind of mind-blowing to see
again like you say a24 has money but
this is just so pristine and also being
that it is you know
a major period piece like this castle
setting even that the round table is in
is just so gorgeous looking and then
these exteriors and whatnot and it looks
like a perfect
blend of this emotionally harrowing very
personal
tale with also yeah this fantastical
adventure of sorts
and an adventure almost feels like a
weird word to use because it doesn't
feel like a rollicking good
time but it definitely feels sprawling
and expansive and
atmospheric you know thinking about like
what the king arthur movie is that i
love the most for me it's
ever since i was a kid it's always been
the movie excalibur
and that is a very dark epic fantasy
film like it's a movie i shouldn't have
watched when i was a little kid i
shouldn't have been watching that movie
and very expressionistic
yeah no absolutely this is not the same
kind of uh
flair what i love about how they've
executed
their production design the actors and
the way they've dressed them
up and just the the gritty look of them
feels
very historically human and accurate
like they don't feel fantastical the
humans
they feel very grounded in reality but
the world they inhabit
feels very fantastical but also very
oppressive
yeah and i love that tone i like the
tone of this
was just so visually striking everything
looked like a composed painting
i was so into i was not expecting it's
been a long
morning not a lot of sleep and that
trailer just like
wow i uh i was mind blown by it i just
want to go back and drink every frame up
and even some of the more subtleties
like like the the weird time lapse with
the stars like it looks like they're
doing some really inventive
expressionistic stuff with their visual
language as well as the
actual faithful recreations of the
setting you know i love how
everyone in this world and i don't think
they're gonna acknowledge it
i just think it's really cool that like
even the arthur and the knights of the
round table
are a bunch of white guys but then you
got def patel the nephew of king arthur
yeah
clearly an indian guy and i love that
they cast him for that yeah and i don't
know if they're gonna make a
like some type of commentary or ethnic
commentary about it it's just that the
idea that they actually
went through and cast him forward i
think is awesome but yeah i mean beyond
all that though too you know
it also looks genuinely really scary
like it's a lot of the vision like with
the giants and then uh whatever he's
being like with hell like when he's tied
up a lot of the way they play with their
focal lengths
and these shots you use the word
expression and that's exactly what comes
to mind here
is this whole thing seems to really
capture a mood
and that mood is something i'm very much
drawn to
i hope because i remember the teaser
trailer rocking but it didn't get me
pumped the way this one
yeah yeah like man him just freaking
carrying his own head out
i'll see you in a year like
and even some of this like almost
religious iconography like their crowns
look like
halos out of old paintings and stuff
like that like there's just so much in
this trailer that you could pick up and
look at and go wow
i love this uh unsettling almost
uncomfortable
mythical world that we're inhabiting
feels like it also feels like a damn
cool video game
a little bit of dark souls touch yeah
let's get that green knight rpg
let's do this guys what did you think of
the green knight trailer
one for the ages subscribe click that
notification bell hit that like button
by the way check us out on patreon last
but not least
bradley bledsoe we messed up yesterday
we should have shouted you out
it was your birthday yesterday bradley
i'm so sorry man
happy belated birthday happy b day i
hope
your wife did some good things to your
ding-a-hole you know what i'm talking
about see if i make it ambiguous you two
might not know what
you're joking they don't know where to
ding a hole i don't know what a
ding-dong
or a butthole like no you don't know
it's a little bit of a combination of
but let me just tell you
what it is i think you've earned a trip
congratulations on the new daughter
persephone monica belushi matrix loaded
thank you so much for everything you've
been doing for us with this channel
lately
been a major help and a major
contribution dude i just hope that you
are able to have a relaxing time
this week i know the times have been a
little rough so you've earned the time
to chill out a little bit
and uh play with your ping-a-ling you
know come play with my ding-a-hole
let's do this